Lisa Marie Presley's daughter actress
Riley Keough is set to become the sole
Trustee of her late mother's estate that
means Riley will effectively be in
charge of her grandfather Elvis
Presley's Legacy that decision resolves
a legal dispute between Riley and her
grandmother Priscilla Presley six months
after Lisa Marie's death at 54. but how
did it get to this point and what does
Lisa Marie leave behind
Lisa Marie was the sole remaining heir
of Elvis Presley when Elvis died the
estate was valued at only 5 million
dollars you know 25 million dollars in
today's dollars
his ex-wife Priscilla stepped in to try
and save the estate
that involved opening Graceland to the
public in 1982.
so essentially the property became
instead of a drain on the estate with
maintenance became a money maker for the
family Elvis Presley Enterprises was
also set up to manage the estate's
assets Lisa Marie took over the estate
and Elvis Presley Enterprises in 1993.
estimated that by the time Lisa Marie
turned 25 and fully inherited the estate
it was valued at around 100 million
dollars that turnaround would not last
long
in 2005 Lisa Marie sold the majority of
Elvis Presley Enterprises but retained
ownership of the Graceland Mansion
the sale was to help clear 20 million
dollars in debt according to a 2018
lawsuit filed by her former business
manager she accused him of letting the
estate dwindle away
and he in turn counter sued accusing her
of living an extravagant lifestyle
against all better advice so we know
that money was being spent in big
quantities
details were laid out in court documents
filed last November related to her
divorce from her fourth husband
they revealed Lisa Marie was spending in
excess of 92 thousand dollars per month
that included expenses for her young
twin daughters
she received around 104 thousand dollars
per month on average from epe
and took home a monthly salary of 4 361
as an employee of Graceland
she had around ninety five thousand
dollars in the bank and nearly seven
hundred fifteen thousand dollars in
stocks bonds and other assets
but she owed 1.8 million dollars in
taxes
overall the filings indicate Lisa Marie
Presley's net worth was negative 3.8
million dollars in the months before her
death
Lisa Marie's assets were held in what's
called a living revocable trust with her
three surviving children as
beneficiaries
but here was where things got
complicated
in 2010 she named her mother Priscilla
and former business manager Barry Siegel
as Crow trustees Priscilla Presley says
she discovered this document purporting
to remove Priscilla and Barry and in
place Point Lisa Marie's daughter Riley
Keough as a trustee Priscilla said the
signatures didn't match names were
misspelled and various trust rules
weren't followed so Priscilla asked a
judge to declare the new document to be
invalid and to keep her position as
co-trustee to oversee her daughter's
assets
in June Riley Keough asked an LA court
to approve a settlement that will see
her become the sole Trustee of Lisa
Marie's assets those include the
Graceland Mansion and the proceeds from
a life insurance policy the settlement
also included an undisclosed one-off
payment to Priscilla who will also be
paid a monthly fee as a special advisor
to the trust a spokesperson for
Priscilla didn't respond to a request
for comment
immediately after the settlement was
reached in May Priscilla said she was
pleased to resolve the situation
Riley's lawyer didn't respond to
multiple requests for comment the legal
dispute played out as the Elvis brand
expands to new audiences and revenue
streams
the king of rock and roll's Legacy will
endure under a unified front for now
[Music]